today on the matt walsh show more major
cities and state draconian mandates
segregating the unvacs from society this
must be done because we're all in this
together they say also the data on
omnicorn keeps coming in and all of it
indicates that there's no reason to
panic just don't tell the media that
plus louis c.k has a new comedy special
out the left says that this somehow
proves that cancel culture isn't real is
that true plus in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the social media
influencer who recorded a choreographed
dance routine in the hospital with her
severely sick newborn baby all of that
and more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
you know it took me a while before i
really started thinking about life
insurance and the fact that this is
really a moral obligation that i have to
make sure that my loved ones are taken
care of in case anything happens to me
and the great thing is that um if you
are just thinking about getting life
insurance now um it's not as daunting a
task as you might think because there is
policy genius to help all you got to do
is um head to policygenius.com and enter
a few questions about yourself answer a
few questions by yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius their license experts will
help you understand your options and
apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
company what that means is that you can
trust them because uh you know they're
not trying to they're not gonna be
biased they're gonna offer you unbiased
help and advocate for you at every step
until you're covered so that's as simple
as this just head to policygenius.com to
get your free life insurance quote and
see how much you could save again that's
policygenius.com
you know from the beginning of the
pandemic we've been harangued and
harassed by people screaming at us that
we're all in this together but it's also
been clear from the beginning that some
asterisks were needed you know for that
phrase actually every word needs one
what do they mean by we who is we
and what do they mean by in this in what
exactly and in what sense are we whoever
we are in whatever we're in together
these questions are left unanswered but
the powers that be continued to insist
on this framing in ways and in contexts
that are increasingly creepy and
orwellian so case in point just
yesterday boston mayor michelle wu
became the latest big city mayor to
impose
strict vaccine mandates that will
exclude unvaccinated people to include
young children from participation in
pretty much every aspect of everyday
life she's calling this policy her
be together initiative
that's really what they're calling it a
policy which segregates thousands of
city residents from everybody else and
prevents them from participating in
society is called the be together
initiative here she is explaining it
today we're announcing that boston will
be implementing a requirement for proof
of covet covid19 vaccination for certain
indoor spaces which we're calling our be
together initiative
be together will require proof of
vaccination to enter indoor dining
well three three categories so you can
keep the count first indoor dining
including bars and restaurants
secondly indoor fitness venues such as
gyms
and third indoor entertainment
recreational and event venues such as
theater shows or sports games
starting january 15th
customers or patrons ages 12 and up and
employees at these locations will be
required to show proof that they've
released received at least one dose of
the vaccine and this will phase into
requiring two doses on february 15th
we're also setting dates for children to
be vaccinated to enter these spaces
beginning in march
yes we're going to bar them from certain
indoor spaces to include um all of them
you know all of the indoor spaces
but we must all be together uh yeah we
must all be together now get the hell
out you sick filthy bastards quite an
inspiring message and it's a message
that we're hearing with increasing
regularity and ferocity uh supposedly in
response to the omnicorn variant but the
attempt to fearmonger over omnicorn has
gone wrong in some kind of hilarious
ways just this morning cnn brought the
ceo of northwell health on the air which
runs dozens of hospitals in the new york
area
and instead of getting the scary message
they were clearly hoping for
instead the guy can hardly keep himself
from yawning as he discusses the very
mild covid situation in new york at the
moment listen
yeah we're doing very very well very
manageable there's no crisis um so let
me just give you a little bit of
perspective but we have right now about
460 patients in our hospitals that's
less than 10 percent of our overall
capacity
and
this time last year during the second
wave
we had almost a thousand cases this time
last year
and compared to where we were back in
the first wave
we had 3 500 patients in our hospitals
so when you look at the numbers today
they're relatively modest
and that have been increasing you know
relatively slowly since since
thanksgiving
we do expect an increase now over the
holidays but it is all manageable
um we will be able to deal with this and
i think it's time for people to get be a
little bit calm
uh you know a little bit more rational
and uh while the positivity rate in the
community is increasing dramatically
that does not mean that they
automatically convert into
hospitalizations
i mean i love that it's
like everyone be calm everything's fine
this is no problem
and my favorite part is the cnn anchor
visibly pouting you can see you can see
him he's pouting as he's told that
there's no crisis
everything's fine
like no people really aren't dying from
this very much and everything's fine
we've got plenty of hospital beds
and this guy he's he's distraught
i feel bad for him
i mean i'm sorry cnn anchor that more
people aren't dying from this i know
it's tough for you tough break for cnn
really sorry about that
but this isn't going to stop the power
mad despots like mayor wu or de blasio
or biden or voucher any of the rest of
them from ranting about the dangers the
winter of sickness and death that's upon
us and in student instituting more
orwellian policies all under the guise
of we're all in this together
let's stay together be together but what
does that really mean well when they say
it we must understand that coming from
them
we means you and this refers not to
covid but to their control and together
is not intended to be understood as any
sort of consensual unity
they mean together in the way that
hostages during a bank robbery might be
together bound at gunpoint
so we're in this together means you are
under their control
and that's how they can justify
segregation division separation
exclusion
in the name of togetherness
we can still be together in the sense
that they mean the phrase even as we're
divided like wheat from the chaff and
some portion of us are cast into the
furnace
and yet as we look around
we see that another just today another
well-known democrat this time disgraced
pervert katie hill uh used to be in
congress but she couldn't have she
couldn't stop having sex with her with
her staff members and now she's not in
congress anymore she was diagnosed today
with covet she is double vaxxed and
boosted she joins senator elizabeth
warren who is triple jabbed still came
up positive for covet this week senator
cory booker another one cnbc host jim
cramer is down with covet now too
despite having three shots
democrat representative jason crowe has
coveted now too along with his three
shots of the vaccine this is all just
this week
an outbreak in congress happening at the
same time as an outbreak during uh in
the end in the nfl among fully
vaccinated nfl players
lots of people who've gotten three doses
of vaccine in less than a year are
getting sick
but we can't ask any questions about
that
you know i recently had to go and get a
tetanus booster after getting a rusty
nail
stuck in my foot
and which wasn't a really fun experience
and but they recommended it because it
had been more than 10 years after my
last shot
and uh and that makes sense to me a
booster after 10 years makes sense okay
i get that conceptually i can understand
how
and i understand how you would call that
a booster
but a booster after six months
is that a booster shot or more of a wait
this isn't working let's try another one
shot
is it a booster or a do-over
that's a question
but these are questions we're not
allowed to ask
whatever you call the third shot or the
first two it's clear enough that people
who got all three shots or two shots are
contracting and spreading the disease
lots of them are
the vaccine doesn't stop transmission
if there's compelling evidence that the
vaccine even significantly slows
transmission i haven't seen it though
i'd love to see it if it exists
that's why the vaccine mandates are not
reasonable i mean leaving aside the
ethical issues and the constitutional
issues those you know those small
details
the these measures are not a rational
response to the situation
because vaccinated people are spreading
it also
we are all potential carriers we can all
catch it and spread it
as it is written there is no one
righteous not even one well it might
also be written that there is no one
immune from spreading covid not even one
they want to separate us into classes of
clean and unclean but it turns out that
i guess we're all unclean
and and maybe there's a certain beauty
in that a certain unity
because it turns out they were right all
along
though not for the reasons they thought
we really are all in this together i
guess
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you might not know that the garage
is the most frequently accessed entry to
uh most people's homes but
even in spite of that it's often
overlooked uh the garage is still where
people you know come and go and they
also keep a lot of their
most prized possessions there including
cars tools and bikes and everything else
so it's just kind of common sense to
know what's going on inside the garage
introducing the myq smart camera by
chamberlain the only smart camera
optimized for the garage brought to you
by the leaders in garage door opener
technology with features like live video
streaming recorded events motion
detection detection and two-way
communication right from your phone you
can make sure that your garage is secure
24 7. and if you want you can pair it
with the myq smart garage control which
means you'll never have to worry if you
left the garage door open you could take
care of all that on your phone
um the myq camera is easy to install and
you can quickly connect it to your phone
via bluetooth in the my queue app it's
just that easy so what are you waiting
for give the gift of a myq smart garage
camera to tech lovers this season if you
act now you could save 46 percent for a
limited time by entering wall should
check out on myq dot com slash walsh
that's 46
wall should check out my queue dot com
walsh keep an eye on what's happening in
and around your home's busiest entryway
with the myq smart garage camera it's
the only smart camera optimized for the
garage
so a little bit more on on omnicorn
because i think that um
this is this is just really important
with all the fear-mongering going on in
the media
even if you know better it's it's easy
to fall victim to it um because the more
this is drilled into your head
after a while it kind of breaks down
your defenses
but
that's why we have to continue
to highlight the fact
that when we're talking about omnicorn
it's extremely mild illness
according to all the data that we have
and according to according to the this
is how you could tell the real like
public health experts the real doctors
from the fake ones
because the real doctors are on tv
saying look this is not a big deal
for most people
and then you see how that message gets
filtered through people like fauci and
the way that he interprets that
so here is um this is in the new york
post uh talking about the
the telltale symptoms of the surging
omnicorn variant it says a noted a noted
british doctor is highlighting several
symptoms that distinguish the omnicorn
variant from the common cold and even
other strains of covid19 including
drenching night sweats
dr amir khan described the
distinguishing episodes as those kinds
of drenching night sweats where you
might have to get up and change your
clothes
the other telltale symptoms of omnicorn
are a scratchy throat as opposed to a
sore one a dry cough fatigue
and uh and
muscle aches
he said well this is important it's
important that we keep on top of these
symptoms if we're going to track
omnicorn and track it worldwide we need
to be able to test people with these
symptoms
so those are the um
the telltale signs of the omnicorn
variant
that your
night sweats which i mean that's that's
unpleasant when you wake up at night and
uh
you're you're drenched with sweat
a scratchy throat
you're tired you have some sore muscle
eggs
now i know they say that this this is
what distinguishes it from the common
cold
but the fact that you can confuse it the
fact that so many people might confuse
it with the common cold i think tells
you something
because to me i read this and this
sounds like a relatively mild illness
this is basically a cold
that's what it is
uh for all intents and purposes for most
people
and again the doctor who originally
alerted the world about uh the omnicorn
variant
she has been ever ever since then
you know she she did the right things
like this is a variant that's out there
let's tell people about it and that was
the right thing to do
but then the world freaked out and ever
since then she's been on tv saying there
everyone calm down this is not a it's
not a big it's really not
anything to panic over
so she was also on cnn she's with the
with the same anchor i think john berman
um
talking about the situation in south
africa right now
after omnicorn surged through swept
through and it's only been a couple
weeks i mean we first heard about this
right around thanksgiving
and what's the situation right now
because keep something else in mind
when you look at the hospital data the
mortality
we looked at some of those graphs
yesterday some of those um some of those
charts
and you can see that there's a very
distinct separation between cases
and hospitalizations and deaths because
cases yeah cases are surging that line
is going up
okay that graph is that some that's a
mountain right there
uh that's a mountainous peak of cases
but then you look at hospitalizations
and death and they're all the way down
here
they're lagging far behind
if you go back a year ago
you'll find that obviously the cases the
the hospitalization and death line was
much lower than the cases but they were
tracking in in kind of the same
direction as cases went up so did if
cases if there was a dramatic rise in
cases there'd be dramatic rise in
hospitalizations and deaths we're not
seeing that right now thank god
but one thing that we're told from
the panic porn peddlers is that well
hospitalizations and death
deaths they lag behind cases
so just because we're seeing we're not
seeing that a bunch of people are dying
right now that doesn't mean
that they won't die in the future
they tell us hopefully
because that's what they want they
actually they want people to die of this
so they can continue selling the fear
but that's why i think it's important to
go to south africa okay if it's been
it's been several weeks now
and um if
hospitalizations and deaths lag behind
cases then we should see now in south
africa after this thing tore through the
country
we should see that uh people are dying
left and right is that the case let's
check in with the doctor
doctor we're thrilled to have you
because i think in the united states we
can learn a lot about your experience
over the last month you've been dealing
with this now for quite a long time
we're just beginning to deal with it now
so i just want to start with cases what
are you seeing in terms of the number
of cases at this point up down stable
what
um good um good afternoon
yes it's very interesting question
what we currently see is our cases sort
of um we're over the curve it's sort of
coming down it's um you know in whole
thing we which was the epicenter the
numbers much lower
uh it is however still spreading to the
eastern western cape and quasi-natal
because of the holidays um but you know
all over in total if you look at our
numbers it's it's it's going down
our positivity rate still stays high is
about around about 30 percent and the
reason is that people go and test
okay so that's the way here it's there's
a very steep drop-off in cases and then
that's cases but then when we go over to
deaths which they talk about later in
fact i can look at the graph right now
in south africa they have a seven day
average
um
of deaths at 44
in the entire country and for
comparison's sake you could look back in
january last year in the winter
and their seven day average was five at
its peak the seven day average was 577.
so a peak of 577 seven day average and
now they're down to 44.
after this dreaded variant of omnicorn
ripped through the country and got
everybody sick
this is all very very positive news
if if you are
a irrational and moral person and you
don't want people to die and you
actually want to be past all of this
then this is very good news
as i've been saying for weeks now this
to me as a non-public health expert and
as a non-doctor
okay i don't i don't claim to i'm unlike
fouchy i'm not going to sit here and say
that if you disagree with me you're
disagreeing with the science i don't
claim to be an avatar for science a
representative of science um because
nobody can be but even i can look at
this information
and see that well
this could be the the end this could be
kovid's end game
this is a positive development
what i just read was now they think that
uh it's something like 70
of all coveted cases in america
i believe i'd have to check that again
but i'm pretty sure it's at seven around
70 percent of all cases in america right
now are the omnichord variant
so this is the dominant strain in
america
now that tells you how infectious this
thing is
that it was able to sweep through that
quickly
but we haven't seen this stark rise in
deaths okay so that that tells us again
it's very it's very mild and that's a
that's a good thing
covet becomes a basically a mild cold
that it's it's out there and it's kind
of seasonal and people get it and they
most of them get over it and then you're
fine
on on covet i want to show you this as
well
i i don't know if you're ready to meet
this person this is the most pathetic
man potentially in the history of the
internet and i know that's quite a
statement but i think he's in the
running anyway he's he's in the
competition this is a guy walking
through an airport do we have these uh
pictures
um
oh here we go so this guy's name is
aiden
and by the way of course he has his
pronouns listed as bio i don't have to
tell you that
and you can't really see his picture
there very well but he looks exactly as
you expect him to look
and he says spotted in the united
terminal
at san francisco airport i've been in
four airports this week and far from
travelers far more travelers flaunt the
mask regulations in u.s airports versus
the canadian ones i hope i'm not sitting
next to her on this red eye and then you
see a woman who's just like sitting on
the phone
uh without a mask on
and so he's taking a picture of this
woman to publicly shame her and by the
way posted this to twitter
this is against the rules now this is
supposed to be against the rules they
take up they they very they're very
explicit about this to take a picture of
someone and post it without their
consent is against the rules that get
you banned
but he's walking through the whole
airport and taking pictures of him then
he gets another guy
man watching something on his tablet at
uh gate e4
so there's just a guy
watching something on his tablet and
he's taking a picture of this guy no
consent and he gets
there's another guy he takes a picture
of him
[Music]
i think there's one in the airplane as
well so he's just walking through
man with stylish backpack between gates
e4 and f5 so he's given the exact exact
coordinates of these masculist people at
the airport i don't know for what reason
does he think the fbi is going to swoop
in i'm not sure what exactly he's trying
to accomplish
um
and then he's got man super spreader
gate f5
that guy is a super spreader aiden has
decided of course his name is aiden by
the way everything about this when i
first saw that i think this is i thought
that's got to be some kind of parody
there's no way this is too perfect
a guy named aiden with a mustache and
pronouns in his bio
walking through the airport crying as he
takes pictures of maskless people
um
but it's not a parody this appears to be
completely real
and he's just determined that he's also
decided by the way that all of these
people are sick
and he goes on and on how many pictures
are there he's now he's taking pictures
of minors of kids
posting them online without consent this
is perfectly okay
twitter's not gonna take this down
all right so we get the idea
um
he's decided that all these people are
sick
this is the way that his his his broken
brain
works now or does or fails to work
that every single person he sees
if he sees their face in public
they are direct threat to him
and they're all sick
and they're all super spreaders i mean
that one guy was sitting by himself
there's no one else around
and but he's he's now a super spreader
this is
along with a mental illness this is
also pure cowardice you know c.s lewis
said that
that courage is the form of every virtue
at its testing point
and uh which means that you know you
can't
you can't really have
any other virtue if you don't have
courage
because in order to in order to
act upon any virtue
in order to be virtuous then that also
requires
courage
to act in that way
so then what does it mean when we become
a country of cowards
when we become a country like this with
with me i i hesitate to even call him a
man only in a by only in the biological
sense is he a man
but what does that mean
and if we become a country of cowards it
means that we have no virtue at all you
get rid of uh courage you get rid of all
virtues
and these are people who
are not only cowardly but they have no
shame i mean there have always been
cowards in the world right
but in the past you'd be ashamed of your
cowardice you wouldn't want to advertise
it
if you found yourself walking through
a public area
uh shaking like a leaf in fear
because you're afraid someone's gonna
get you sick
in the past you might have that
experience if you're a very cowardly
person but you keep it to yourself you
wouldn't want other people to know
now you've got
people like aiden
advertising their cowardice for for
everyone to see
they're proud of it they're proud of
being fearful cowards
that has become its own in our
upside-down world that has become its
own virtue
now it's almost as though cowardice is
the is the form of every virtue at its
testing point
all right let's move on to this kim
potter's trial went to a jury
deliberations yesterday she's the
officer who shot dante wright
and um
jury
went to deliberations yesterday did not
come to a verdict here she is i just
want to play this for you this is a
couple of days ago during her testimony
she decided to take the stand
and um
in in her own defense
and here she is kind of describing
the scene and when you watch this
describing what happened with dante
and when you watch this you gotta you
gotta think okay is this a
a remorseless killer
is this someone who really who we feel
needs to be punished
in addition to the psychological and
emotional torment that she's
experiencing
i don't know you watch this and uh you
decide
did you say anything when you saw this
what did you do we were struggling we
were trying to keep him from driving
away
it just it just went
[Applause]
chaotic i it
[Music]
and then
i
remember yelling teaser taser taser
and nothing happened
and then
he told me i
there are many scenes like that when she
was testifying she's just
totally broken
um
by this experience
that's that's pretty clearly not acting
i mean this is someone who's who's
devastated
it's a normal woman that's all it's like
a normal person
who was
thrown into this situation
and uh and did make a mistake
like nobody's denying that in this in
this case
um
i i still think that that would have
been
the best defense actually would have
been to say well i did it on purpose but
she's being honest there's also no
getting around it because she says on on
on tape that it was that it was an
accident so she acknowledges that but um
if
if it were possible to say that this was
that this was done intentionally then
there'd be no case at all
because when you're dealing with a
violent suspect who is fighting back
against you and then tries to climb back
into a vehicle
i think you have every right to shoot
him
because you don't know if he's grabbing
for something
you know he's wanted on a weapons charge
you know he's a violent criminal
so you don't know if he's grabbing
something and even if he isn't
this is what i said about the jacob
blake case
yeah jacob blake was armed he was
reaching
and then he was shot and i guess and
that's the reason why that police
officer was never brought up on any
charges because he was reaching
but i would say
even if he didn't have a weapon
and even if somehow you knew he didn't
have any weapons in the car
you'd still be justified in shooting him
i would have shot him
because he because when he gets into the
car that becomes a weapon
a violent dangerous suspect in a vehicle
is not that is now a
you know a multi-ton
weapon that he is going to be driving
around at 60 plus you know 100 miles an
hour or whatever
that becomes a giant battering ram that
he can run into anything and then in
jacob blake's case also there were kids
in the car
and so i think taking the gun taking the
knife out of it taking everything out of
it
i think you're perfectly justified in
shooting him dead right there to stop
him from getting into the car
and i would say the same thing for dante
wright
you cannot let him get in the car and
start and start driving away because
that's when people that's when an
innocent person might get killed that's
when one of the cops might get killed i
mean suspects use vehicles as weapons
against police officers frequently
um
so if she had simply done it on purpose
and said yeah i did it on purpose
then i think there'd be no case at all
in this case though we know it was an
accident
but now the question becomes
you watch that testimony and you think
about the whole situation
does this seem like the sort of person
who we as a society need to punish
is she someone who needs to be is she a
danger to society does she need to be
segregated from society she's already
lost her job obviously she's not going
to be police officer anymore
um you you could you could certainly
make the argument that you probably
never should have been a police officer
but then you know that brings up a
conversation that nobody wants to have
about uh about
there are a lot of female police
officers out there who are not
physically capable of dealing with
violent male suspects
that's conversation nobody really wants
to have
so she's not if she's not a police
officer anymore is she a danger to
society does she need to be segregated
from society for that reason
clearly not
um is she some sort of remorseless
sociopathic killer clearly not
did she make a mistake clearly she did
she feels terrible about it
it's probably already ruined her life
not probably it has
i i don't know what throwing her in
prison accomplishes
i look at this in some ways similar to a
tragic case where
you hear about
one of those things you as a parent you
worry about so much you know a parent
backing out of their driveway backs over
their own child and
and kills them
um
you know unless the parent was really
being negligent and reckless and was a
drug addict that was you know like
unless there was something unless
there's some kind of exiting
circumstances normally when you look at
that you say well are you going to put
the parent in prison for that
their life is already ruined they they
are more distraught over this than
anybody else
what what what does the punishment
accomplish then it becomes just cruel
adding that on top of
this tragic event which has utterly
ruined them
so it's similar to that only not so
similar on second thought because uh the
child in that case is an innocent victim
dante wright was not an innocent victim
and he was not a child who's a grown man
violent criminal and uh he's the one who
created this situation so when i when i
look at kim potter
on trial
for her life
distraught her life is ruined you know
who i blame for that i blame dante right
you know i get angry at dante wright for
doing that to her
he did that to her
if he was alive he should be the one
apologizing just like jacob blake should
be the one apologizing to the police
officer had to shoot him
because you're a violent scumbag
you've lived your whole life victimizing
people at will as dante wright did
victimizing people in
brutal savage ways
and then you have a police officer
simply trying to do their job to bring
you in because you're a dangerous
criminal and that's what they're
supposed to do
and you decided to fight
because you don't care about the law you
don't care about the rules you don't
care about anybody
and a terrible accident happened in the
process and someone like someone's life
is ruined
a good person's life is ruined because
of you so i i put the blame on dante
right
um
all right let's go to this from the
daily mail it says
a hero wisconsin mother of two died
eight days after suffering suffering
severe injuries when she saved her
four-year-old son from being brutally
attacked by the family's pitbull
heather pingle 35 for bowler suffered
kidney failure lung damage and both of
her arms had to be amputated after the
pit bull viciously attacked her and her
son
she was rushed to the
aspiris hospital where she died of her
injuries on december 16th
damian received uh
70 stitches to his leg and his back and
is back home recovering uh that's her
son
damian
so she had both her arms amputated and
then eventually she died
yeah i bring this case up because it's a
horrible case but also
uh
yet again i think it emphasizes that
it's uh it's simply crazy to
allow these these animals to be
owned
you know in in our neighborhoods
this kind of thing it happens every
single year
it is not all that rare
pit bulls are very dangerous animals
they're bred to be dangerous
they are uniquely dangerous
not every dog breed is equal in that
sense some dog breeds are more dangerous
pit bulls are the most dangerous
because they are bred to be aggressive
they're bred to be fighting dogs
they're built like machines
and you could say all you want but i
have a pitbull and he's so cute and i
put funny hats on him and the kids he
would never hurt anybody no he's a he's
an animal
okay
and if he has a bad day or if something
snaps or something triggers
you know someone does something innocent
but that triggers an instinctive
reaction in the animal he's gonna become
uh he's gonna become a
death machine
mauling children killing women this
happens every single year
in fact the website ban pitbulls.org
which i think they put their biases
right there in the url but it's but even
so the information is good
it says um
pit bull tax in the u.s
rose 700 so this this information is a
little bit old
but since 2014
it says pitbull attacks in the u.s rose
773 percent
between 2007 and 2014.
in the 10-year period from 2005 to 2014
pit bulls killed 200 americans and
accounted for 62 percent
of the 326 total recorded deaths by dog
bites
um
and uh
and then it goes on with more statistics
but you you can look up yourself but
vast majority of maulings happen by
pitbulls now if you want to look at dog
bites in general including just like a
nip on the hand pit bulls might not be
at the top there probably like a poodle
would be at the top but poodles poodles
aren't killing anybody
so
severe maulings pit bulls by far and
away responsible for most of them
um
they killed 200 people in the span of
seven years now
yeah you could say well you know many
more people die of car accidents every
year so on and so forth but
this is we're talking to hundreds of
people
mauled to death by animals
by animals that we allow into our
communities
why
i so i know what the argument is for not
allowing pit bulls so ban pit bulls
the argument is that these can be very
very dangerous animals uniquely
dangerous and they kill hundreds of
people and they maul thousands of people
and and young kids get their faces
ripped off and so
that's why we should not allow pit bulls
that's the argument for banning them
what is exactly is the argument for
allowing them
the argument is they're cute i like them
that's really a whole argument that's
just that that is not an argument
this pit bulls are not this is this is
not uh we talk about the right to bear
arms because i know that's another thing
pit bull apologists will often make this
comparison what you're doing this is
just what the uh what the gun control
crowd does with guns
yeah you have a constitutional right to
bear arms
there's no constitutional right to bear
pit bulls
football is an animal and there are all
kinds of animals that you're not allowed
to bring into neighborhoods and i would
think that most of us would agree with
most of those you can't bring a lion
into most communities will not allow you
to um just own a lion and have it
hanging around in the backyard
is that an infringement of your
constitutional rights
no and why don't we allow lions well
because
yeah i mean
there are probably cases of people
having domesticated lions and not
getting mauled by them but they are
uniquely dangerous these are wild
animals um
it presents a threat to the community
and there's just no good reason to do it
so your desire to have a lion does not
outweigh
the desire of your neighbor
to not have his child's face bitten off
that's the argument okay this from the
new york post it says
the headline louis ck's new sorry
special proves cancel culture isn't real
critics say
and the article says louis ck's sorry
act is no laughing matter to some social
media watch dogs the controversial comic
is hyping a new comedy special as many
viewers learn this weekend over a
commercial break during a very sparse
episode of saturday night live due to
the fresh coven 19 outbreak in new york
city
um
the aptly titled sorry shot over the
summer at madison square garden is the
54 year old comedian's first since he
faced numerous allegations of sexual
misconduct in 2017
and that's actually not true he's done a
couple of comedy specials so they're
wrong about that but anyway um he he
recorded this comedy special and he
streamed it on his website where you
could go and buy it for ten dollars and
that's and that's where it was it wasn't
on netflix it wasn't on amazon or
anything like that
and uh there were a lot of
leftists on social media who were saying
oh you see it you say the cancer culture
is is real but
now louis c.k is still performing comedy
and he's got a comedy on his website
how does that negate the reality of
cancel culture
we know that louis ck was canceled
because this
comedy special was not streamed on
netflix or amazon
prior to the scandal
right this would be on netflix and he
would have gotten paid you know
hundreds of millions of dollars to do a
series of specials like dave chappelle
has
for netflix
so he's doing this on his own website
he's been he has been barred from
uh most of these platforms they're not
going to go anywhere near i'm not going
to touch him
and uh he's not you know he's not doing
the late night shows to promote it like
he would have done beforehand
and he's got to just put it on his
website so yeah that that still
qualifies as cancelling
doesn't disprove anything
but it does make me wonder
you know the advocates of of cancel
culture while they claim that it doesn't
exist
what they really mean is that they think
it should go a lot farther than it does
because you're taking issue with louis
c.k doing a comedy special and and
putting it up on his own website
do you think
you think he should be prevented from
doing that
i mean it's a free country he's not in
jail he's a comedian so this is what he
does this is his craft and so he's still
going to tell jokes so what you seem to
be saying though if you're on the side
of oh this proves cancer culture isn't
real
what you're really saying is that you
don't think that he should be able to do
that
so walk me through that exactly
somebody ends up in a scandal
they're they're not brought up in
charges they don't go to jail so they're
still a free person walking around
and somehow you think that they ought to
be prevented from
producing content and putting it on
their own website that's all he's doing
or maybe it's because maybe we're saying
cancel culture isn't real because uh
yeah he's free to do the comedy that he
wants to do and he's free to release it
on his website but the real what they're
really taking issue with is that there's
an audience for it
that's what they really are upset about
that probably
i don't i don't think we have those
numbers but probably millions of people
went and downloaded it
and people still go to louis c.k shows
so maybe that proves that canceled
culture isn't real
no you know what that proves here's what
it proves
it proves that louis c.k
whatever you think of him in his private
life
is a very good comedian and he's funny
and so
people still want to hear him tell jokes
that's all that proves
in fact if he can survive
the scandal and still have an audience
and still do these shows
then that's that's just a testament to
the fact that he's a very very good
comedian
that's all and it also shows that a lot
of people in the audience
um
are able to separate a person's private
life
from
their craft or their art
and if you're on the right you know
you've you've gotten very accustomed to
this
that's one of the reasons why there
isn't much of a canceled culture on the
right there isn't one at all
i mean the main reason as i've said
before is that the left owns all of the
institutions and cancel culture is
something that is
that is that that happens from the top
down
it's it's it's it's institutional power
you know cancer culture is a mechanism
it's a tool of institutional power the
right doesn't have any institutional
power
but the other thing is that is that i
think people on the right
don't really bother going after people
further things have in their private
life and scandals and all of that
because we we have gotten so accustomed
to separating
who a person is and what they do in
their private life from the craft
because if we if we were not able to
separate those things we would never be
able to listen to any music we would
never be able to watch anything on tv
we wouldn't be able to enjoy any kind of
entertainment at all
because when it comes to private life
and all of that kind of stuff we object
to almost all these people
and yet if they are good at their craft
we can still uh separate that and and uh
enjoy the craft of what it is you know
the holidays are already an expensive
time for uh for most people and uh this
is gonna be the most expensive holiday
that most of us have have experienced
because of inflation and also gas prices
if you're traveling you're gonna pay a
lot more for gas and that means you
gotta you gotta take advantage of any
opportunity you can find to save some
money and here's one opportunity get
upside that's what it's called it's an
app you can get it at the app store and
uh or google play and it's really simple
it gives you 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time you fill up uh use
promo code walsh and get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price the pump anymore get cash
back using get upside just download the
app for free and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch now there's no fine
print there's no red tape the cash is
added right back to your account you can
send it to your bank account you can use
paypal you can get a gift card anything
you want to do just download the free
get upside app and use promo code walsh
to get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback
on your first tank that's code walsh
and also
you know this season my pillow wants to
give back to our listeners you can get
great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com right
now and click on the radio listener
specials there you can find deep
discounts on my pillows mattress toppers
towels and so much more for example just
one example of the deals you can find
there my pillow is offering a buy one
get one free offer on giza dream bed
sheets these are top quality sheets once
you uh use these sheets you're not going
to want to use any other sheets ever
again that's true for all my pillow
products all my pillow products come
with a 60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty so go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener special for
the buy one get one free offer on the
giza sheets and use promo code daily
wire at checkout or call 800-651-114
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including pillows
slippers the my pillow mattress topper
and the my pillow towel sets and much
more that's mypillow.com and enter
dailywire or call
1-800-651-1148 and tell them daily wire
sent you again that's 1-800-651-1148
all right let's get now to the comment
section jolene says i think you're right
about 2024 matt if trump would endorse
desantis that would be amazing i would
just hope florida would uh get just as
good a governor to replace him and maybe
someday pa will be that lucky lol
yeah that's actually the one argument
against desantis running that i'm
sympathetic to especially if you live in
florida and i've heard this before no i
don't want the sanders to run because
then we lose him as governor so i
understand that argument
um
but you know i i think that
because
he is a governor specifically
he has shown an ability to govern and uh
so that's a skill that
we know will carry over into the
presidency
i mean you could have a very talented
conservative senator who's really good
in their position doesn't necessarily
mean they'd be a good president
because it's a different skill set
i mean if there's actually any skill
involved in being a senator which i'm
not totally sold on but there is
definitely skill involved in being an
effective governor
um
catherine says matt i'm glad you found
something for your son boys are easy to
shop for but in my experience grown men
are hard to shop for why are you guys so
picky see i understand this i hear this
complaint from women a lot that uh men
are hard to shop for we are we are so
easy to shop for you know why see women
you you make this more complicated than
it needs to be and with all due respect
you you tend to do that in general in
life you make things more complicated
than they need to be because you're
overthinking it
men are very easy to shuffle all you
have to do here's here's the
here's here's the process okay
there's a man in your life you're buying
a gift for whether it's your father your
husband whatever boyfriend
um
so here's what you do
you go up to them and you say
hey what do you want as a gift
and they'll tell you and then just go
and get that thing whatever it is that's
all
let's see the problem for for women is
that well you actually know what the men
in your life would like as a gift but
you don't want to get them that because
it doesn't feel it doesn't feel creative
enough enough
you know you think that it's the thought
that counts the most
what you don't understand is that it's
the thought that counts
that's a that's a female mentality
that's not how we look at it as men
like we actually don't care about
if i'm given a gift that i want and it's
something that i want
i don't care if there was no thought put
into it at all makes no difference to me
um so that's your own mentality so ask
the man your life what they want and
then go buy it and yeah here's the thing
like every man in your life there's only
like two or three things that he wants
and it's always the same and so what
that means is that for every gift giving
occasion you're just getting him the
same thing and that's fine
i mean the gift is for him right it's
not for you so get him what he wants
um like my dad for example
all he ever wants as gifts are gift
cards to restaurants where he likes to
eat that's it that's like the only thing
that he wants
and so for every gift giving occasion
and we have tried through the years
especially my sisters or my mom i mean
they've tried through the years to try
like get him something else oh we
thought we thought this would be cute to
get you instead maybe maybe be
interested in this
but then he's going to see that as a
project that's almost like an assignment
a chore
where you're giving him something he's
not interested now he's got to develop a
whole new set of interests and whole new
hobbies to use this gift i'll just give
just give him what he wants that's all
um
freedom underground says walsh is an
ageist l.o.l damn yeah i'm ageist
against 78 year old presidents i am
i'm i'm 100 ageist against 78 year old
presidents
i am ageist against anyone over the age
of say 75 running for president and i
think that it should be banned and i
think it's crazy that it's not banned
35 to 75 that should be the time frame
run for president you got 40 years to
get it done you can't get it done then
that's it you had 40 years to try uh
nice try now go home and be with your
grandchildren
live your remaining years in peace it's
actually it's it's really a gift in fact
that you're not going to be president
there's already this problem
where um
oftentimes
the people less the the people least
qualified to be president are the ones
who most want to be president
in fact the very desire to be president
uh
is is a red flag in and of itself and so
that's the catch-22
but that is even more the fact for when
someone is elderly
i mean if you're 78 years old and you
want to be president
at that age
you would actually you actually want to
take that on
uh that just tells me that you are
a narcissist an egomaniac power mad all
the rest of it i mean look at joe biden
um
let's see alexander says sorry matt
desantis already said he isn't running
so leave your tds at the door and get on
the maga train
well he didn't say that he's not running
as far as i know he said he is going to
run for reelection for governor that
doesn't mean he's not going to run for
president
and uh tds trump derangement syndrome
criticizing trump is not tds okay i
criticized lots of politicians on this
show if you watch this show you know
that do i have derangement syndrome
about every politician that i criticize
or is trump the only one that you can't
criticize without being deranged
even when he does and says things that
you would criticize anyone else for
doing and saying
still it's derangement to criticize them
come on
uh free cat says gossip is negative by
definition it does not refer to casual
sharing of stories it's usually
embarrassing or completely made up given
today's climate you should treat your
home like a military base the less
people know the more secure your home is
um i agree my point about gossip is
simply that women gossip because they
actually care about what's happening in
other people's lives
and that can take on negative forms at
times
where they care about the you know the
things that they that are really private
they should be talking about but i think
it's born from
something positive which is which is
that they actually care about what's
happening whereas whereas men
largely don't care that much about
what's happening other people's lives
that's not what we feel like talking
about
like we're not gonna sit down and talk
about we might talk a little bit but
we're not going to sit down and have an
hour-long conversation about what's
happening in somebody else's life
not because of any moral superiority but
we just don't care like i'd rather talk
about football or politics or something
like that
and finally paul says matt i have to ask
you if you think covet is real or is it
something you think our government is
using for power because it seems like
it's affecting the whole world i agree
mandates are dangerous but your attitude
is equally dangerous
so why can't it be both
it's real and it's something the
government is using
so there's a little bit of a false
choice there all right pretty excited
about this folks i have four daily wire
promos to tell you about so
buckle in and get ready for this candace
owens is one of the few voices in
america that isn't afraid to ruffle some
feathers which is why the daily wire
sent her to mar-a-lago to interview one
of the most censored men in america
president trump they discuss everything
from the potential for another
presidential run in 2024 why he didn't
pardon certain whistleblowers and what
he really thinks about alec baldwin all
of that is covered and you can see that
tonight at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on dailywire.com
and and if you want to show your support
for truth seekers like candace head to
to yesweekcandice.com up some awesome
candice merchandise as well
and there's more ben shapiro's newest
show the search is excellent and if you
haven't watched it you're missing out
the show is a voyeuristic view of his
closest and most influential friends and
as they share their inklings and
personal lives over coffee his great
friend jordan peterson is the first to
join him and it's truly an excellent
watch all episodes are exclusive to the
daily wire so if you want to be able to
watch this you got to become a daily
wire member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and
the daily wire is making it easier to
listen to all of our content on the go
with our launch of listen which means
you'll now be able to listen to all of
your favorite daily wire content on the
website and the dw app why do we call it
listen because that's where you listen
so that was there was a marketing
a lot of marketing meetings to decide
what we call this and we decided let's
call it listen listen is here to make
soaking up our content as convenient as
possible with a limited ad audio
experience so make sure you go there and
do that and also
not only was the daily wire the first in
the nation to sue the bite
administration for their
unconstitutional mandates we're less
than 50 000 away
from hitting our goal of 1 million
signatures on our do not comply petition
why because people are realizing that if
we don't actively fight for our freedom
the government will take it so go to
dailywire.com do not comply
and uh make sure you sign that and our
one millionth signature will win a
million dollars i totally made that up
so forget about that but still go to
dailywire.com
do not comply
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have to cancel a woman named
whitney levitz who has amassed a
following of half a million fans on
tiktok mostly from what i can tell by
lip syncing and dancing while pregnant
now tick tock has proven that there's an
enormous market out there for 12 second
videos of people lip-syncing and dancing
but in order to really make it big on
the platform you need to discover your
own niche within that category your own
twist
so some people lip-sync and dance while
only partially clothed
some people lip-sync a dance dance while
not clothed at all
others lip-sync and dance while wearing
funny outfits there are people
lip-syncing and dancing while
cross-dressing you know
i saw one woman who was lip-syncing and
dancing while being very old so that was
her own special variation on the theme
and all these people have like lots and
lots of followers on tick tock but
whitney had the pregnant lip sync dance
genre cornered until her tic-tock career
was derailed because she had her baby
and so she was no longer pregnant and
searching for some new creative
inspiration she found her opportunity
when her newborn child came down with
the respiratory virus rsv
now three of my kids had rsv as babies
all of them had to go to the hospital
for it
and i can tell you it's an extremely
scary experience because while the virus
manifests as a cold in adults much like
omnicorn it can kill a very young child
unlike omnicorn um
it would be an understatement to say
that while at the hospital with my
severely sick children i was not in a
dancing mood now to be to be fair i'm
never in a dancing mood but if i were to
ever experience the strange and
arbitrary urge to move my body to the
rhythm of music it would not be at the
hospital with a sick child
now whitney on the other hand takes a
different approach to parenting and so
she recorded and posted this video at
the hospital while standing next to her
newborn child who was struggling to
breathe let's watch
[Music]
now for those listening only to the
audio let me paint the mental picture
for you um whitney wearing a bright pink
nirvana sweater despite i'm sure not
being able to name more than two nirvana
songs at most
that's beside the point uh whitney is
standing in a hospital room next to a
newborn child
performing a choreographed dance routine
while the captions on the screen inform
us that he has rsv has low oxygen levels
and cannot breathe well on his own
now we should note that it's not even a
sad song and dance either this isn't
like an interpretive performance where
she's communicating her sadness and
anxiety through dance
that would also be completely insane but
this somehow manages to be even crazier
because the song and dance are upbeat
meanwhile her son is laying helplessly
in the bassinet
looking at the camera with a distinct
get away from me woman
expression on his face
now
if you really wanted to make excuses for
whitney which i don't
you might argue that all of the dancing
nurses over the last two years have
given people the mistaken impression
that hospital rooms also double as dance
studios
i'm just glad that this trend took hold
after my achilles surgery a few years
ago because if i had the same procedure
today i'd probably wake up from
anesthesia to discover that there's a
viral video on tick tock of my surgeon
dancing around my unconscious body while
he stitches together my shattered
tendons tendons
so i think i've escaped that sort of
thing um but now my nightmare is that
you know sometime in the future i'll go
in for some routine blood work or
something only to have the doctor and 15
nurses come dancing into the room with a
marching band to inform me that i have
stage four cancer and i'll be dead in
three months
that's where this is headed now all that
being said this is no excuse for whitney
who should have known better all the
same and she now acknowledges that and
she issued a tearful apology a couple of
days later after her video failed to
receive the applause that she was hoping
for this is what she said
i understand people are upset
with the video that i made
i just want to be clear and
communicate that that was me just trying
to be positive
i think it's important to to just not
just assume
what someone's going through
anyways i took the video down
because i could see
you know
where somebody could get the wrong idea
but that honestly was just me just
trying to be positive
in this situation but
i do want to say thank you for people
who
have reached out to me and my family and
i just really appreciate it
yeah well she's the victim here you see
the victim of the content that she
posted on the internet to her massive
crowd of followers
she says that she was just trying to be
positive
well there's certainly nothing wrong
with that
people try to stay positive i've been to
plenty of funerals where people are
laughing and joking finding joy even in
grief it's a very common coping
mechanism
but the problem here is not positivity
the problem isn't even necessarily the
dancing now if i walked into a room and
found a mother dancing alone around her
sick child
i would think that it was super weird
and i'd be very uncomfortable having
witnessed it but i'd probably assume
that it was some kind of like religious
ritual or something
the main point is that it would be none
of my business
if i were to just walk into a room and
see that
if that's how you cope in private well
okay that's your affair
but this was not private
she made the decision to record edit
and post this content to the internet
she wasn't merely staying positive she
was using her child's sickness as
content for social media
she didn't stay positive she stayed
posting and that's the issue here
speaking of funerals this reminds me of
the influencer a few weeks ago i think i
mentioned on the show who found herself
in the middle of a similar firestorm
when she posed for seductive photos next
to her father's open casket and posted
them to instagram and she captioned it
butterfly fly away r.i.p poppy you are
my best friend a life well lived now
once again
there's nothing wrong with that
sentiment the problem is that she felt
the need to post pictures of herself
with her dad's corpse on social media
that's not coping that's content
what should have been a very personal
and private moment becomes an
opportunity to bring attention to
yourself
now she justified herself the one with
the corpse
after the fact by saying
everybody handles their loss of a loved
one in their own way some some are more
traditional while others might come
across as taboo
for me i treated the celebration as if
my father was right next to me posing
for the camera as he had done on many
occasions prior
but again
she's free to grieve in her own way to
celebrate her father's life in her own
way to go through this privately in
whatever way she sees fit it's none of
our business
unless you make it our business
which in this case she did
and when that happens we are free to ask
why i mean what motivates people to
bring these sacred and intimate moments
into the public sphere
exploiting their own trauma for content
cashing in their grief and misery for
likes and shares why do people do it
i think there are a few factors but one
that we could consider is that um
you know this new crop of social media
influencers
grew up with the internet on it in it
they've never had a private life
they've been on stage effectively almost
since birth living in front of an
audience
now everybody knows that child actors
usually grow up to become deeply
disturbed and troubled adults why is
that well because they never experienced
normal human existence
they were famous before they could
understand what fame meant and certainly
before they could really choose it for
themselves
they've been performing for so long they
never had a chance to develop a real
personality
a real interior life so they grow into
these stunted hollow people
and they try to fill that gap in that
hollowness in with drugs and everything
else
well the problem is that now all kids
have child actor syndrome
the only difference is that most of them
don't have millions of dollars to show
for it but they get on the internet and
social media early in life
and they begin cultivating their own
little audience
and they become small scale public
figures performing for the crowd
trying constantly to appease and grow
their fan base
though they can't explain what they gain
from it
and this is true of adults too everybody
is a public figure now
on one scale or another everyone is
famous in their own way
only most people get the worst parts of
fame
the lack of privacy the narcissism
the constant crushing fear that you'll
become irrelevant
but none of the perks money admiration
success
and this is how we end up with people
who put everything on the internet who
publish publicize every detail of
themselves
who use every experience and every
thought and every misfortune and trauma
as content
mere fuel to shove into the fire
that's how whitney levitt happens though
this is not an excuse
we still must hold individuals
accountable for their own behavior which
is why today she is
still at the end cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show oh macron
is now the dominant strain of covet in
the united states joe biden threatens
the unvaccinated with illness and death
for christmas and the white house gives
up on joe manchin that's today on the
venture show give it a listen